moi je crois que personne ne comprendra
qu'il n'y ait pas de
texte la semaine dernière le débat n'a
pas pu se faire c'est quasiment inédit
c'est regrettable c'est incompréhensible
maintenant je crois que les Français
attendent qu'il a un texte il y a des
attendus qui sont extrêmement forts sur
l'immigration et donc nous devons
aboutir il y a un travail de fond qui
est mené pour essayer de trouver des
positions de compromis c'est ça la
politique j'aurais préféré qu'elle se
fasse à travers un débat parlementaire à
ciel ouvert mais la priorité c'est que
nous puissions avoir un texte sur
lespr on se passe de mesures qui
permettent d'expulser des délinquants
qui permettent de raccourcir des délais
qui permettent au fond d'apporter des
solutions au problèmes que les Français
constatent mais les discussions se font
en majorité avec les
républicains c'est pour ça que je vous
demande est-ce que vous ne craigz pas un
texte trop vous dites il vaut mieux un
texte à droite plutôt que pas de texte I
qui résulte des débats nous repartons du
texte de la majorité sénatoriale c'est
la démocratie parlementaire que ça et
donc il faut le respecter faut essayer
de trouver les bonnes positions sur
chacun des sujets il y a un énorme
travail qui est mené un énorme travail
par le ministre de l'intérieur par la
première ministre elle-même en première
ligne pour trouver dans notre vie
parlementaire les compromis nécessaires
pour que nous puissions avoir un texte
efficace sur l'immigration il y a un
certain nombre de sujets qui étaient sur
la table qui était les sujets les plus
difficiles celui de laame celui de
l'accès aux a social celui du droit du
sol celui de l'hébergement d'urgence sur
tous ces sujets-là vous l'avez entendu
avant moi étaé présent Philippe boncar
qui est un des sénateurs qui sera
présent dans cette commission mixte
paritaire il y a un travail de fond
minutieux utile dans l'intérêt général
du pays qui est mené et moi je crois
qu'on peut aboutir qu'on doit aboutir et
qu'ensuite si l'étape ce soir cette
commission mixte paritaire est passée il
faudra voter ce
[Musique]
texte